today we're talking about a cursed item
in elden ring that's getting players
banned as well as a huge update coming
to battlefield 2042 tomorrow
now this is gonna be the weirdest start
to a gamespot news video ever but if
you're roaming the lands between an
elden ring and you see a pair of panties
laying on the ground
do not touch them these forbidden undies
are a piece of leg armor called the
death bed smalls the item reportedly
belongs to a set alongside the deathbed
dress but unlike the dress the panties
are unobtainable through a quest and
seems to have been cut from the game's
final release now this should be where
the story ends but pc players have of
course hacked their way into equipping
fia's panties one of these players
ironically named pansu dealer is
invading other worlds and leaving the
cursed item behind for unsuspecting
players this has resulted in tons of 180
day ban reports from players on the
elden rings subreddit so i repeat if you
are roaming the lands between and you
see a pair of panties on the ground
leave them there do not touch them in
other elden ring news the famous let me
solo her is now an npc summon thanks to
mods this elden ring celeb is a
pot-headed hero who has been soloing
millennia one of the game's hardest
bosses and helping other players who
were having trouble taking her down
themselves well now thanks to eldon ring
mater garden of eyes you don't have to
wait in line for a chance to have let me
help you with the fight this mod
replaces the game's lone wolf ashes and
can take millennia out pretty quickly
however it's important to note that this
mod is locked behind a patreon paywall
of five dollars but alright that's
enough elden ring for one day there are
a lot of changes coming to battlefield
2042 tuesday april 19th and i am not
exaggerating when i say a lot there are
over 400 changes in total including big
changes for weapon attachments voice
chat functionality and improvements for
the end of round menu for weapon
attachments dice said its goal was to
help make them feel more unique in the
current setup some attachments felt too
similar making it difficult for players
to understand and appreciate specific
unique attributes about each as for the
scoreboard changes the new ui for this
will now display at the end of round
screen as well as displaying in-game the
addition of voice chat is pretty
straightforward it's now available for
parties and squads this was one of many
features that players have begged for
since launch there are also some changes
to specialists such as rao now having
one of pake's traits sundance being able
to leave grenades sleeping on the ground
for ambushes and mckay more easily
grappling moving vehicles but no changes
towards a more classic class system yet
the file size for this patch has not
been disclosed and this is a very small
sampling of what the new patch will
offer for the full list click the link
in the description of this video now is
this update gonna be enough to bring you
back to 2042 or are you just waiting for
godzilla to get into warzone because i
mean there is a new tease and it looks
like it's definitely going to happen so
let me know which one you're more
excited for battlefield or godzilla
and don't touch those paintings you know
you know what i'm talking about all
right i'll see you tomorrow